[Applause]
right now heading off to show time to
meet up with Brendan to do
I guess just check out their home
facility how they're gonna do is show
the brand-new show that's coming out
with Brennan and then I'll have to be
working back and forth with the show
time as well so it's good that we meet
today and kind of figure out you know at
least got to know each other a little
bit let's see what happens
we got this new iMac in to handle all
the extra workload without with the
Showtime show and the Showtime
deliverables and this is supposed to be
more powerful and faster than the one I
have already but it's actually a little
slower so it might be just an issue with
this particular computer I'm not sure
but this has to go back now and then
from here we order another one and
hopefully fingers crossed it works well
so this is great help
[Music]
I'm Ashley
I can't leave now my car's over here in
this garage and I can't leave this place
because of the March
[Applause]
sure
more power to the Marches I kind of knew
something was going to go on this
morning but I have no ideas into this
it's pretty crazy
[Music]
and how many fingers you used to do it
honestly to no more than three
take em is it Christmas okay second
question um everyone you know is pretty
much dying right yeah and most your
family's in a fire okay who do you go
back in to get my son
okay all right Dan though it's gonna say
I'm serious sorry but god bless him and
god bless your friends in that past okay
how about this dude you things don't pan
out right the modeling the modeling the
wrestling none of it works out right Oh
W be either the brown belt or whatever
the new food service you're offering is
none of it works out what job you end up
getting honestly you have to move back
to have to move like the Good Witch yeah
Denver which is basically I'm through
the [ __ ] it's a Cleveland of the
mountains Denver you have to move back
to Denver I'm working on a fence more
three president British ow shell I'm
back at it with a fresh new feed so the
clock is gonna get here now I'm gonna
head downstairs to pick it up
what's up dude how can that sucker fit
in there maybe we can try let's give a
shot
what's your name dude nice oh yeah
that's the only the way wake and she's
how heavy this thing for you ah I'm sure
that's a cake for leader I mean does it
mean is it hard for you to pick up are
you cold
[Music]
I wonder if it'll go to the door we have
a tiny space right so I'll move stuff
around but I think we're gonna put it
well I have to probably lightly put it
down and open it later right yeah sure
so let me just I guess we'll just leave
it here then in this area I mean move
the stuff oh yeah
[Music]
all right okay Paul and you just this is
just ridiculous
and it's from Russell built and you just
called me yesterday we talked about this
and there's like special instructions
and how to take it out of the box which
I need a power drill cuz these are all
screwed in with a Philips then once I
actually take it out of the box I can I
have to lift it up in a certain way but
then I got to put these feet on it and
it has to be level to the ground so the
pendulum swings perfectly they should
look badass in the studio wants done I'm
officially on my way down to below the
belt studios Showtime have like 20
minutes to get there it's only ten
minutes away it's actually super close
to where I live
I'll go thank you yeah what's happened
how you doing good thank you
what I was there
good man how are you not that long
okay what's up Jason hey how's it going
in a long time
yeah good to see you Steve here okay you
every single time no 100% on me like
it's doing yet Oh Jen you don't see
that's the way we do it thank you we
should do that from now on just you and
me yeah
it's the way that works yeah no I just
never use them hey good to see you
oh you recording right now yeah I don't
know if they're gonna keep anything but
just just in case dude you guys have the
same hoodie who's that dude are you not
the best I love this camera right you've
been on camera for an ACL reconstruction
that's weak so it's been a problem for a
while then you know I like hurt it doing
yes husband box jumps with the jam that
was very exciting
what you and Ferguson what the hell yeah
Brendan's five minutes out can you grab
him meet him in the lobby yeah yeah why
are you here say Anna talk to ya hordes
of Energon back in my life yeah yeah
super asleep you just get used to sleep
taking like a Navy SEAL do bud I was
always like a Navy SEAL now how'd your
surgery go
[Music]
it's the Instagram like yeah nearly oh
you're the overdose are like black dough
just give me a little oh it's perfect
our camera angles are gonna be insane
while you are super moody lighting yes
oh yeah before the videos we got Brides
which is that how it feels is good
delicious it he's gonna send any second
now and then wraps anyone great so we
should be good or anymore no we don't
need next I'm afraid that might be like
we want to keep these things pretty fast
so those are great what we've got is
good if if they spaced out and don't
send it to you like you don't need to
nag them about it a lot of that piece is
gonna be stuff that but that you nervous
it's up to you but I just I don't want
to like beg them for it and then it
comes out and it's short you know what I
can use a minute 15 printed out like
these are using your highlights man
hardy bees got the tongue out and she's
like very photos fury it's funny
whatsoever getting images of fury like
we can go back to when like he's like
five years younger
yeah exactly
my TV they tell you not to do that but
it shows off the watch yeah Deonte is
you know sleep and then after
photos and if he fighting so you want to
get a line here so it looks like one of
those documentaries yeah cuz I'm gonna
be like right here just shooting out
their weird angle it always like there
be involved or you know yeah yeah
exactly
like why don't have to this all right we
do Mic Check Mic Check Mic Check Mic
Check 1 2 3 1 2 3 artists artists yeah
I've got one I'm not hearing him on your
blog I said wait I went up to my mom so
gently like just moved in here I took
her index finger I just move that finger
and the time to start crying
she started crying with
it's so perfect you're talking about the
picture where the rock is poised against
the staircase in a fanny pack yeah turn
off
do you think this do you think this
fairy pack makes you look fat so you
stop right there Mike those jeans up you
get against that staircase you put your
arm like this
it's the single greatest but probably
wasn't hurting most of these guys that
weren't for you yeah so basically if
you're on this side facing this way and
you can look and like you can talk to
the camera for this because you're just
like oh yeah so like you know Diaz
really pushed me to my limits I'll do if
you don't love wrong
Oh to be
and I usually charge for this stuff
donation came out here's the Connor
oh that's but not least money Mayweather
no more we have yet in front of the
camera it'd be our pleasure could you
maybe show us some of what you showed
them he's really pushing to the limit
the LeBron
Oh Salem mainly just Connor could be
Ferguson all those guys
firing back live like a real talk I've
been lately yeah all right you've been
Harry you don't seem we haven't been in
this part oh [ __ ] so I'm digging it this
is where we shot the [ __ ] with Brian and
the WWE stuff yeah grab anything you
want him but I got you some sriracha so
we'll start over here I'm gonna be at C
low to cinema Cammy hello 3027 oh I
[Laughter]
don't I don't get what question you're
gonna have I don't are they not answered
in the art I mean how many question you
guys have I don't I'll do it I'll do it
I'll do it
I'm not x lunch
hey [ __ ] lunch 12:12 similar to what
you did earlier you stopped like Brendan
will be ready for you in just a few
minutes just double-checking some things
with the cameras but just make yourself
comfortable
yeah yeah I would never say this on
there ever but uh you seen the Rogen
fanny pack big-time big-time get back
get back
hey we're we're just about ready for ya
we'll be out there and maybe maybe three
minutes but uh just hang tight
we'll be with you in a minute see Cal's
rash
I gave it to do yes people think it's
funny and stuff we're just doing thrall
my producer chin on the podcast gay
I think it's Sarah killer - I don't I
don't know what he do from the weekend
please gear you see her come with white
blood on his shirt we just I mean last
when he does during the weekends it's
just there's nothing there's nothing so
either the killer or I think you just
wearing some weird sex fantasy something
like that [ __ ] creepy I think pretty
big net I'll tell you nothing will trust
and boys at Showtime I don't I don't
alright Brendan we're just about ready
for you so we're rolling now alright
thanks for sitting down with us yes
they knocked out zach gowen Africa
that's the wrong on my way to San
Francisco all right well I'm on my way
to San Francisco in about one hour so
I'm gonna try to do as much as I can to
get this thing set up
the bus'll built clock
look at this mofo holy moly I don't
think this camera can actually capture
how big and massive and awesomest walk
is this is ridiculous it's so trippy how
everyone that gives these gifts to the
show they make such amazing crazy-ass
badass pieces of work I mean these guys
are super talented man this is really
not a one-man job is the pendulum
well look at that all these different
welding spots
haha this is the feet he's talking to me
about or he was telling me about before
on the phone he's gone underneath you
know securely set to the ground just
gonna call homeboy what's up dude do a
great man so I'm actually I'm gonna fly
out within the next 20 minutes but I'm
trying to do as much as a clock as I can
right now I got out I got it out of the
box what about the the electric thing
inside the cord does it go up the clock
er on the bottom of it where does that
go at the bottom okay okay it looks good
yeah is it like a little black point
gotcha yeah I think I got pretty much
everything here man so I think we're
good I just want to make sure that I
didn't have to do something inside the
bottom before you just said what
happened the sensor so good to go yeah
cool I'll take a picture
I think Peter as soon as I'm done I'll
send it to you and then I'm also a video
taping this too so will eventually put
this in some sort of video
we appreciate you dude this is friggin
awesome so it's so cool to see in person
it's so different
[Music]
[Music]
will do I appreciate it
[Music]
I know do you see this but as we look
the first batter he goes pretty good see
if I can do it on camera I don't have to
do this afterwards when I get back from
San Francisco
damn murder foam I do love it we love it
yeah yeah what about getting one myself
that takes away all the low rumble
sounds okay so you want to keep that on
at all times keep it at zero - that's
called unity game okay
so I'm just gonna stop by first there's
two cops and then the third one came
over and I was actually freaking out
like what the hell did I do they pulled
me over and he talked to me for like ten
minutes just about camera stuff and
about the podcast and everything else is
pretty cool so shout out to those cops
and this is a wide angle and already got
on OK 7 to 14
here in San Francisco just landed
just landed and I'm gonna actually go
into our office day to listen finishing
touches on that that new clock that we
got from Russell built so it is 935 p.m.
on a Sunday and I'm gonna be working it
for a little while so this thing needs
to be broken down so I could at least
put it against the wall or against
something in the meantime before
figuring out how to get rid of it and to
do that I have to unscrew all the parts
that are screwed in on the sides and
then figure it out from there
[Music]
[Music]
alright this is gonna take a lot of work
[Music]
[Music]
today is Tuesday April 17th and I'm
heading over to Shake Shack right now to
bring over the teams and burgers because
we talked about yesterday on on upload
the belt so I've got hundred for it and
I wanted to try some more and Mike
Catherwood is our guest today there's a
shack and there's a car blocking the
street and I don't know where I'm gonna
park
the parking around this area sucks balls
the lines not even that long
how's it going Kevin yeah awesome you
said we were thinking pickles she starts
off on the side of like like shake
we are go back to the studio yeah ed
Holmes kind of knows what he's doing
that's a pretty good go so what is your
name my name is Rudy dog nice to meet
you I'm a big fan thank you rather I
appreciate you watch the coma city to
the Goldbergs yeah oh my God look at you
in your short shorts I look at that meat
that karna you got in your pants are
like full and thick I'm kind of jealous
you know you're from LA Rudy I'm born
and raised doc I barely ever left one
time I went to TJ with my uncle but yeah
so um what do you think you want to say
in this animated series is there any
like family guy but you're Mexican it's
like more like go like go king of the
hill focus like you know how like they
told a story about East West Texas talk
you know yeah and they really brought
that world to life for the mainstream
yeah I want to do that but like for for
you know East Los Angeles you know what
I'm say let people know it's like a
colorful world no it isn't alone I got a
you know beautiful wife with a fat ass
you know she was getting a little too
like fat like her pants ah her [ __ ]
Fupa was getting yeah and she tries like
me try like CrossFit and [ __ ] the
Weight Watchers yeah none of it worked
you know so I do it I had the do cuz I
see her like at night she would grab her
[ __ ] Fupa and she'd be like crying
yeah so I started putting meth in her
food what oh wow like secretly you put
my Reaper dog give me some stunts and I
put it in her food
did it work if she lost 125 pounds
there's been a big girl now
she's like 78 pounds off because it
seems she's shocked up her arm because I
thought there are bugs in it oh yeah
that's like a downside yeah it's a
downside like yeah but you know
effective you know what I'm saying point
A to point B yeah I understand that
there might be a better way to do it
though whatever huh finally I do I do
Asian that makes a man have to think
about the night good but you even Asian
you have to like fine QA that's a very
specifics like I mean I get it that's up
one of the luxuries of coming from
anywhere I came from like I could hear
someone talk again oh she's Korean you
know a person II mean chin when I when I
was on tour in Australia she went with
me and for whatever reason well not from
her reason because of a [ __ ] the way
our world is created Australia where
it's located a lot of Asians go there
for holiday a ton a ton so we went there
I we got off the planet like gentleman
dude I'm sorry am i doing shows in Tokyo
the [ __ ] going on there's a lot of
there's a lot of Asian population -
there's so much there's Lily's weird is
there it was an easy guys I got my hey I
want to do yeah we're gonna [ __ ] the
Kangaroos weather some age and I had I
care but then I'd go I'd hear on the
plaza go Jim what were they speaking it
tell me Jim wear these feet you tell me
and then by the end of the thing
Gymkhana they speak of like that's
Korean that's jammed Britney caught on
yeah it's cool many Chinese miss cool so
there's a big yeah
[Music]
[Music]
primarily my way to Showtime right throw
punches strong check out something no I
just want to I'm actually listening
listening to the Rogan podcast with
Kevin Lee and Kevin Lee is actually
going to be there at the studio today so
I might get some footage of that too
cool simple straight up I will say I'm
gonna get the mics open beforehand I see
humor yes okay you will see in here
women you'll see him you'll hear him in
his ear he will only hear you he cannot
see this is Brennan's greenroom for the
show there's me
camera that I mean everyone will
eventually announce it it's more of a
guy listening Jacobs right yeah so
that's the but this is about who would
win yeah he's now ready to fight someone
like lomachenko tank look damn good but
is he ready for a pound for pound great
one with chanko it's too much too soon I
think you do better than we all would
assume but no no no don't do this to the
man don't do it no change is the best in
the world they have all time but when
it's all said and done
starting with baby slice looking down at
Bellator 197 baby slice really come to
his own is Papa Kimbo
I'm sure it's awfully proud of them it's
really getting dynamic and we get the
submission win wall somewhere so I need
a two-shot and over the shoulder no
sticks sticks
[Music]
yeah I guess he's getting in there
around noon yeah yeah yeah we're gonna
have lunch with them after this Oh Kevin
yeah yeah it was Kevin's I agree really
high level high level dude all right
I've seen some video it's great man I'll
go JJ Whitehead he's more athletic Rob
gets hurt too much boy gun cows keys
hurt all the goddamn time French press
[Music]
it was like alright so that's not
working
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
all right no on my way to grab Nick Nick
Swardson he should be done he stay for
today's episode 355 dvj all right we got
next words in the house
what's up with you Nick what's up man
how are you good what you got coming up
uh nothing no no um I go on tour
tomorrow look for two months
I'm tickets are at Nick Swardson net I'm
going all over I start in Vegas and then
I'm in San Francisco Sacramento this
weekend and then I go out and hit
Florida and all over the place so I'm
really excited that tour is called many
smells we saw the whole one seriously
who farted seriously who farted yeah I
know I'm maturing really really well
into my 40s now so should be good but
this shows are going great and the fans
are awesome so yeah yeah come on nick
swardson dotnet for ticks hell yeah it
was 10 minutes early he was telling it
like a half hour late he told me don't
worry about being on time he's always
like nah dude what the [ __ ] is going on
what the [ __ ] going on that's a way to
say that who put this on me no but you
obviously did we put it on your oh yes
you coming to our you come by so much
sure that you I made the trip well
what's with your shirt your shirt is
even air oh my god that's even wait so
you broke into my house last night and
put this on me when I was sleeping yes
and if you put that on because he's
obviously I was what you like but well I
put this on you and you got out of the
shower Oh
we got a lot of stuff in let's check out
some of the stuff new SD card that I
need no more stuff and this is my iPhone
for cable cuz I still use an iPhone 4
for my iPod and I don't think it's
charging anymore so that's what this
guy's for now this I'm super excited
about these your belts and this is where
my camera microphone they put finally
dies for a while so I have to do some
voiceover see all these different plates
that one this one this main plate which
is a the main logo this abbot kinney
plate and then this T fat K plate so how
this all came together is I basically
just went online and looked for my
favorite T fat kilo lows whatever I
could find online and once I had those
picked out I just reached out to the
team to get the high quality version of
those logos and then I saved them to
this folder right here so you could see
him here there's a Abbot Kinney one
there's this fire the kid with Brendan
Bryan there's this FK one this T fat K
one and of course the main logo so all I
did was I just took all those different
logos I dragged him to my desktop and
then I just started like arranging them
in a certain order like any random order
and then I just picked out whatever or
to look best to me so I would move this
over here that over there that over
there and then this main logo in the
middle cuz that's where it belongs and
then I remember thinking this FK over to
the left and then a K on the right this
looks like the best sequence what looks
best to me in my eyes so I sent that
over to done dispute it and this is what
you got
there's the belt and I took a picture
just in case you couldn't see it that
wall and this makes it a little easier
but it's still super shiny so anyways
the top says t fat k guest of the year
still super shiny can't see it and the
bottom says 2018 champion because as you
know Theo von is a 2017 champion so
that's pretty much how the belts came
together from my own place that I think
we're gonna use just to have like
digital notes written on and I'm gonna
couple this with an actual monitor to
look at videos for below the belt so we
don't have to keep moving monitors
around this is a table over from Amazon
so we can put it to the corner where
Brennan sits down at four below the belt
someone else ordered a different table
beforehand but it was just too flimsy
and weak so I got to pick this up I like
this it's nice and thin just good for
the mics
[Music]
[Music]
I'm at this is the original table
they got but you can see this suckers
digging in to the wood with that do you
see the indentation you can't a crappy
table or a weak table when you have
these pretty heavy microphones and
microphone stands and on top of that a
clamp that needs to be securely locked
down into it and this is like no joke
three two pounds maybe two and a half I
feel like it's made out of cardboard how
do you like that 3 glyph drives that's
how much we need right now probably need
more in a bit and this is what it looks
like if you don't know that's my
backpack full of gear
well gearing like one hat
[Music]
call me I'm like dressed like a wrestler
[ __ ] take the title w hook a dirt
what if you're doing episode we delete
one time and I come in and just [ __ ]
take the [ __ ] title brother just like
I took it from him on the [ __ ] boat
it does look so sick to me the one thing
though like putting it on yeah you got
to put it on super tight cuz it what do
you wear what you think what would you
wear this thing's awesome man
oh no suit is leather yeah here your
brush you didn't ice then when you first
started you know better because you
learn how to stay calm stay calm these
people T off on you like a younger guys
who are not good yeah would be a
possible anything I'm Lesley my so has
muscles
these are lengthening okay and they're
exercising and the lower gluten is
engaged so subsea difference let's call
this that's my proper posture as opposed
and also sleeping I can't sleep on my
back but they said to put the pillow
under the knees you get the flattened
out you know your course or flattened
put the pillow here on your stomach you
put one under your stomach Dudesons I
don't mean to switch it up I switch that
trouble sleeping like for I never get
both out some coffees a day but go ahead
know that mean watch
folio bone marrow Atlantica okay do you
have a skeleton this is just bone marrow
this is enough on each other
yeah so you're gonna take a strong
jellyfish and that's all it looks like
and you want the strap daliyah come get
it boys on the rats and happy so I'm a
Rexy do you any other boat you come get
it what they hit her come get it and I'm
taking this thing on tour with me every
show I go to be there you want to get a
pic with the strap just boxing his
championship another late night Monday
is 1054 10:54 p.m. T fat K is uploading
this is one with Theo von guest hosting
for I don't know if it's a third or
fourth time now that's uploading sending
a file to our Video Editor that does our
Instagram videos D on this is sending
the belt episode to Showtime I've
already uploaded it to the show times
YouTube channel and then this is the
high resolution low the belt that I'm
just exporting rendering out an
exporting right now and I'll send that
tomorrow so they can have it as a backup
to do super high quality stuff and now I
can finally go home in actually I've had
a write another email with a bunch of
highlights so it's got to do that and
then I'm done for the day
today is Wednesday May 13
and today we have on Matt Mitrione so I
didn't just do there now my day has been
good I got to sleep in a little bit I
had breakfast and I got to have a chill
morning and never gonna go shoot an
exciting interview I'm gonna do Liz
all right so here's what we're gonna do
you guys you did the whole pod right yep
cool so you're warmed up we do a little
segment on his TV show pound for pound
which is basically just a rancor and
it's a chance to take a category and
then rank kind of who we like best in
that category okay so what we want to do
because of your background and and also
Brendan's was ranked though a list of
NFL guys if they transition to the mixed
martial arts okay you are going to have
to give me about four minutes because I
don't know anybody native feel anymore
great so he said yeah once you said
double-check your stuff throw your phone
in your pocket we're gonna be these are
our two cameras I can't I can't use you
want to use it like with a look at
something good oh no don't start talking
low get off track around that's fine I
have a little bit of a football
background not to your depth the
cappuccino of the Buffalo Bills all
right now we're both turned fighters
when you're about to fight for a world
championship pretty soon here but when
you look at the NFL like this question
all the time a lot of people go God
could this guy make it into the UFC to
this guy making belt or this guy making
MMA there's a few guys who could yeah it
would toughness how many not many
I agree not me but through toughness
speed skill set and I'd say the biggest
the heart okay I heard that and on top
of that there's one other small part
that plays a massive role what's that
and is if you are humble enough to an
extent to understand you're gonna take
an ass open in front of five million
people all the time and be able to show
up the next day after that ass-whooping
and still come back from work
up or not the Showtime team we're not
there quick enough
there's buying seats oh yeah it is
my shoulders really better I don't
remember signing consent form Jen you
don't have to worry about it I'm the
warrior show so we're good to go
okay so today we're taking down this
stuff these the equipment we take down
every day let me do this I don't know if
I did it the wrong way but mine didn't
work sorry
you know what that's what I did wrong
yes yes simple that was thank you
one day chin you're gonna catch like a
real crime being committed and and this
is gonna be the central one feature of
some great movie what's funny about that
is that's one of the reasons I don't
have a dashcam on my car yeah I'm
worried if you have it then you're gonna
capture some fancy [ __ ] for sure
I mean Freddie the house that's where
robberies happen it is always on camera
there's a warming amount of stuff that
we never could have known about yeah
previous generations do you guys watch
Barry Barry Barry awesome it's really
realistic but the one thing about it I'm
not giving much away it involves a
hitman so people get killed the one
thing about it that I find really odd is
they just like clearly as a writers room
we're like let's not really worry about
exactly like how much doing is people
are getting away with like and that
there would be witnesses and evidence
all over the place and this wouldn't
work they're just like that
trust us he gets away with it you know
like is that the only bill hader yeah
it's good it's really good I'm gonna see
it - how would you like this done sir
yeah
drop it but are you going back to
downtown no matter what yeah so let's
just you don't why would both of you go
if we can do it all if you're going in
you yeah maybe we could yeah I'll just
put my car around right here right I
mean did you did you capture I can't
really management that I just did on a
camera I was actually gonna look at the
camera state this well [ __ ] put up
with just kidding what a great guy Gabe
is for saying that I'm saving I mean are
all that times all the sense in the
world yeah our each brother whatever
liar another sister Jam
line cut and then we're gonna have to do
live in it all good stuff peace out guys
alright you too man I like to drop these
names and Megan and Megan Fox will say
the same place yeah and then ever
promoted canal from BIGBANG care-a-lot
their favorite person and then you went
to New York yeah I was in New York just
helping let people know what the threats
are you talked about this right got it
back up but you have to back off the mic
dude it's very distracting for me
no oh please
I'm begging you just you don't have to
have your nose that close to it to
please back off the mic this better a
little bit if you did it's a little bit
more no see now you took the mic with
you you can just back up a little bit
just move your head and keep them right
there no no back
stay in the middle too late staple
Center
basically here to meet up with rich
crystal from Showtime and Brendan's
gonna be out here doing interviews stuff
like that so you see that's goes
duck
a beat I'm doing behind behind
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
we will why don't we do a shitty version
of this for you guys yeah exactly
let's try it he's just a hype man on
this hell no no draws the judge can't
pick a winner
you [ __ ] fighting yeah perfect this
judge can't pick a winner guys end up
the results is great
Brendan said we can edit it all together
but they don't give the takes that you
just did that was really really fun yeah
yeah enjoy your time and I like parks
what's up guys today is Wednesday the
20th and we have a pretty interesting
show today which you'll see afterwards
I'm gonna obviously posis afterwards so
first of all I apologize for the audio
is microphone input broke somehow on my
my camera so I'm using just an internal
microphone it's not too bad
anyways this cool day we have a show
that Brendan can't come
so we're gonna have crystal Mia
Wolf's ass is going to surprise
as they're going on
and now I'm walking into the studio and
once again I apologize for the audio if
it sounds like [ __ ] kids it's the
internal microphone don't like pass on
it g85 hi guys how are you tired tired
what times you get in today five minutes
ago are you gonna watch are you you're
not Mexican are you you are you're
playing us we'll see what happens but
it's like 8:00 in the morning to you
right yeah now we're gonna we're gonna
win see how's it what did you [ __ ]
say to me just joking around
alright well I'm not gonna do any [ __ ]
from you today I'm cause it's our show
today
what is it our show today it's a
guessing yeah well you're the guest on
the show that I always find you and yet
you're gonna get go ahead and take a
little seat no this is you mean throne
don't say that take also you you don't
wear those sunglasses why not do I like
from people to see themselves when they
talk to my used are you Lucifer are you
Piazza bub you wouldn't know what Jeff
because I you can't see me well that's
annoying you can't see me oh no I got an
STD oh it was video game that would be
like my name is I want you to call
hunter from now on I want you to call
him video games last name what months
months okay I'm out of here but I know
this guy this boy from Jersey grabbed a
whole ship you're not from Jersey
I am from here's your you calmed me from
Pasadena I'm not from patty I never
lived in Pasadena I moved out here when
I was 12 you the [ __ ] rough streets
at Jersey
no no you live by coin did the term
dirty you grew up in
Pasadena in mansion that's not true
knocking yatta first of all okay with
your mind we would jelly in your mouth
sent you on with a pat on the ass enjoy
lunch pail that's crazy this is what
Brendan and Jen are into kratom which is
actually an addictive Brendan's not into
it anymore
he got vertigo from that he said that
yeah or at least he knows that that's
what caused it because he's when he was
off of it he said that's when I
disappeared almost immediately Wow
so could be into things every now and
then
[Music]
yeah yeah all right yeah yeah Wow the
guy who's gonna catch the ball
oh wow that's that's your sound effect
yep that's an amazing yeah I was very
visual so long it's a little cough yes
it's pretty cool I think I saw ya bye
let's allergic to [ __ ] boring it
isn't that crazy on the spice on this
clock and a ranch hey Chris and I will
come in carry my coffin we're gonna be
like moaning next you coughing like this
were the only pallbearers promoting it
also let me tell you this much if I if I
ever win that I'm making you some
[ __ ] earrings you little words what
happened with the one that I gave you
best woman from last time I was what did
I tell you about that if I don't see it
here next time something's going up your
ass well [ __ ] an award at the [ __ ]
Airport they didn't have it was an
Austin I think I saw that okay it said
best woman he was offended by that he's
a piece of [ __ ] okay guys this is our
fighter in the kid core strength there
you go there you go perfect
yeah you welcome
well the Machine the doing we want we
want thanks guys thank you guys I
appreciate appreciate appreciate
appreciate you guys very much for 7:10
their podcast Oh 1.6 million dollars for
God you have to cover yeah 1.6 made all
for what God II forgot II mean 1.6 and
zero percent on Rotten Tomatoes
okay see you're all 0 don't wait to see
it meet you that pony made me want to
see it yeah it's gonna turn around to
make it's gonna be a cold day trouble
with this [ __ ] out of it I'm surprised
it didn't do movie to because even
people going to see it ironically yeah
yeah here's a look at what my seating
position is from Brendan's point of view
so there's two cameras here that guy and
that guy and then there right there's
where I sit and I talk and I bring up
current events that go there and there's
very a definitely nervous about eating
and stuff you know funny going to China
if you never see deal against cuz you
got kidnapped in China that sex slave
boy
the rats down there they rats a little
bit you know get a condiment map you
need a condiment man world
he thinks Thousand Island dozen comes
from thousand of
so very sad thank you
so I'm gonna bring my family back here
laughter - oh yeah so uh Joe if it's so
it's your mom and then two others yeah
Rhys and I get the net for sure so
they're in opera box order than a
proviso so there are many sides I can
tell you this we'll see what happens I
think might get in trouble speak yeah
which is cool tell me I'm sorry you
didn't Stevie Stevie blue eyes and I'm
here this is Brian in those updates on
yeah Beastie Boy okay we just we barely
like what's up well I just barely got
here dude it was our seventeen our
seventeen from there boy did you book
Midway
yeah thanks crazy tonight it won't
matter for the video shoot we would
prefer to keep your as separate so
tonight we'll just keeping it that all
Wireless
and then for your announced do you want
when you're ready
ardella for next what gifts we do now
okay I'll be working for you I'm gonna
bring my friend enough about register so
there we go this is the this is the
practice run through this is Thursday
one reduce teams can say he didn't even
know that we all we planned Ramsey
hanging out oh you shop stirred the shot
stirs gonna do 20 minutes and think
Thomas Joe 65 nice man
this green house green huh and you were
the green shutters perfect
I'm so dark in here I think there's a
light
is there somebody Terminator hog it's a
supercar I can't
is it the one that's behind the locked
casing and I was like
that does help it sounds a lot tax bill
tell ya it's still tightening my shoes
before Brian's many weekend [ __ ] do you
guys over the side doors oh yeah
[Music]
nine minutes bro this is a cool-looking
alleyway - it's kind of like I feel like
spider-man
[Music]
and does a dope
this long way here
you've been doing it bro oh good George
[Applause]
doesn't take swings thank you
[Music]
a second
[Music]
man
like never
all right
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right got it see you're 51 it's it's
no good at smelling angles we better
have a barrel chest wasn't the girl
chest and I want you can see I'm getting
greater in the back of my head looks old
look like an old man the back of the
head these little things that they
attend Shinto so what I'd like it's a
little more proportionate strong again
lots of steroids this muscular red fanny
Americans expiration special shoes for a
special night it well I'm glad to wear
them because they they in fury if I did
it they infuriating picture Isis what's
up right yeah
hey man you're kicking your you're
terrible
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
how's get [ __ ] me yeah for reals
[Applause]
these are the halls of Italia or Thalia
hall
[Music]
[Music]
doing good by awesome or great
are you really talking in that oh you
are wearing an undershirt what
they can't see the on the top one unit
now let's say they're gonna shoot yeah
it's a good test today
fantastic
especially with the with the sweats
that looks good you can't tell it's
inside yeah that's good
sure - tighter it's okay No Oh - sexy -
sexy really ruins it looks good man
my back hurts I'm good on man
it's okay
he's been another already yeah so he
started at 8:10 he's up for 20 minutes
you said yeah alright so we'll bring up
in like 12 minutes
just to either when he announces you
there's crime so someone wanted this
always what do you think how Marisa yeah
our summer ourselves she supports you
guys like crazy she goes to our
sama-sama that is so sweet she goes to
all your shows right like she sees you
and Brennan she's she's awesome man you
said are selling many times we got that
she has the toughest name and Hank and
she's only coming for one day to see
yours yeah she she's awesome
let me see I can't see it let me see if
I can see it on camera camera I can't
see it at all okay help we're good
but
yeah it does it's tough let's go all the
nerves are gone from street play no dude
stretches these churches
sitting on a flying
I didn't sleep at all in there wait so
that helps you're back early yeah okay
[Music]
your body is like old me it's like an
old car so a movement a movement and
then what you eat makes a difference
because if you get more sensitive you
just get more sensitive your only your
body's responding
I think it's more sensitive this is the
moment
thank you this way
[Music]
yes up here it's past
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
it's so loud I started listening to a
podcast was like four years ago I
started to stand home and then like to
come from there
did their podcast with one
three years and I like to
Brian's special it's like a perfect
little get out of the South cool story
right I mean you can enjoy it if you
want to keep going yeah of course yeah
that's good
[Applause]
pretty much
[Music]
I thought yearning I thought tonight a
visa let their ride my dad lives but
what I take out all that something new
okay
you did it about a million kids I just a
kid
[Music]
[Music]
I feel like you did the UFC
yeah that's where okay I was like oh
he's getting off soon
goodbye always good always amazing thank
you
yeah post-show yeah strippers
[Music]
this is my old boss Jeff he's the one
who taught me everything I know about
audio engineering and voiceover
production
[Music]
Thank You Man what mark chin nice to
meet you
so nice to meet you yeah so I'm just
doing this behind-the-scenes stuff for
Brian to capture all the memories have a
great night guys
oh I'll juvie but I can do I can make it
I can make it a picture I can still make
it a picture afterwards
breaking the law breaking the law
breaking the law breaking the law
what's cold
let's go
[Music]
agente
[Music]
we're investing fun yes this is our sama
otherwise known as a Marisa Karen I
guess my god I'm Marisa are sama he
knows your name is just freaking you're
the worst that's the hardest thing to
memorize it pronounce it is you gotta
say for a while how do you feel today
Brian cool how long's it last night I to
one that's not that long it's taken us
we do nice oh yeah yeah
steak accessories best for my assistant
to the strengthen cetera and they found
that my strength was equal to a
full-grown male around Bhutan it's
supposed to go smoothly - that's just
genetics pure natural testosterone she
came she was surprised it sounds like -
what ever go near her life she's in the
back
some hated Kaufman [ __ ] just for show
[Music]
thank you very much oh this is tomato
paste
[Music]
[Music]
you know the top like deck plate it's
sort of near the front that looks legit
[Music]
everything god damn I'm not even private
isn't really Revit now let's wrap it up
top tricks like real like a real nice
dinner I hope you [ __ ] despite what
this pictures shows I'm actually sober
and they just look like dad sweat Joe
has doesn't fly commercially can I do
so when I get to London he's got this
insane house
this is my boy no no sometimes 18
college so great to see because you know
it let's open a wine this is a Centurion
wine it's one of the wines of the
century
he's got this crazy wine selling this
let's open one of these ones he doesn't
read this paragraph line and Robert
Parker's so this is when you drink this
white pair should go at this new Jesus
Christ taste again because nothing
tastes like that you said oh that smells
like you don't do that that goes you
know that's an experience I've never had
so that's that's good
so we drink it we're talking about
eating a Lebanese food and I don't do it
thank you that was incredible man that
was I can't believe you're the bottle
for me he goes what's up and I'm not
about it's can I come too I
I don't want I want to think thirty
thousand possible then took one year
let's slum it and open one here 1985
Shepherd miss Bob let's go $1,000 one
good son hey I don't want to open this
and he goes we're getting paid to drink
this wine
[Music]
what because I only only six bottles in
existence
I'm gonna drink five and I was so last
one back my money
[Laughter]
hang gliding or German I play baby
stuffs story
you're a story yes because to see old
leaves in agony SEAL Teams this guy and
he was going on this mission for you
where they're at but they need a
translator a guy who speaks the upcoming
Afghani all and so he straps on to our
boy Eddie stuff which is no monster
these straps on there and read for the
gun what do you say boss is bigger than
you or novel just like twins just like
you know like a so he tells me not yet
so he tells the guy he goes they're
about to come back that's the only doing
trainer nothing's nothing's like shaking
no just let me provide needs to sandals
and like a thongs I work 30 feet down so
you guys freeze and cold the shoulders
like you're there to talk with the
people so yeah the logos so he jumps out
the guy is so he's here and the guys I
think guys go on it starts grab anything
no no no no
they start spinning out of control the
guy passed up juice it's it means mouth
it's kind of exerted sugar than others
so the rest of the boys land fine like
six miles up ahead and he's final now
this guy's going to get out of
consciousness and cutting out theme so
he knocks it out until you guys like
this
he's like Foxx Travis we got over your
land and since the guys out what you
used it
he's telling the story like 50 it's like
now you're recording just hire the but I
feel like they're not all howler one
yeah alright that's here like a into my
pen universe big
that's why theater yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
nice
[Applause]
ends up you are
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that iPhone wait so check this out of it
that's her without makeup yeah yeah with
it's like two different people
eyeliner that's probably what it is it's
about the kind of [ __ ] you have she's
she's a hooded eye hooded if it tricks
the eyes think that there's more eyelid
there so makes it look bigger
Sushi's with dark shadow but it's just
with dark shadow and it depends on your
eye shape to begin with but with that
actually you don't have tried to like
the all-black and it just looks like
somebody hit goes at the dark brown if
you have a dark black I said yeah black
really harsh like really harsh like the
nighttime when you actually go out all
right
hey what do we do now we're going to go
clapping definitely I run a club
why not chin you don't like everything
hey of course not because I'm not mean
we're 47 okay fine 45 you don't look I'm
not even I'm kinda sorta not near but
sort of am it's fine you don't have to
flex for the gram you're 45 bucks is for
anything guys it's really 45 looks 47
most days on to get B equals 42 I'm
closer to 42 than everything you said
but what are we gonna go so I can't get
in I wear a beanie all the time and I
don't want to take it off because my
head's my it looks too violent
yeah what is that and what I'll talk
about it started it that's fine but then
also what I have a shape that I look to
stare um you don't fit okay
I do that's what helps you you know what
get through the day no by the way we're
in the green room right now and Brendan
and brought under both out there on
stage weapons out there first
brian's ready to go out and i think
after that everyone's gonna go home
because everyone's getting old and tired
but since me and agent a are close to
the same age we're gonna probably hang
out and do something more fun really
young gay people what's up you're old
enough to be my dad
so since we're closer in age we're gonna
go do something fun okay and you call me
daddy yeah this one I just want to the
top anyhow yes yes yeah well nothing is
a [ __ ] buzz kill yeah hell yeah Brian
yeah it was beautiful it was the best
thing it's the best I can do and I did
the best I can do
I care about family well yeah dude the
freaking room was rumbling from the
applause yeah they were it was just
amazing man it was like it's what I
wanted to do I was nervous I wouldn't do
i wouldn't be careful about what works
unless you go out work don't you don't
rise to the occasion but for me that was
the best
oh yes and come back to you out there
[Music]
yes he stares alright alright
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]